the incomparable Jackie Chan has been
thrilling audiences for over four
decades of a singular combination of
insane martial art skills and great
comedic timing the other quality that
sets Chan apart from his peers is that
he does his own stunts no matter how
dangerous cheating death virtually every
time he makes a movie here are a few
scenes that posed grave danger to the
life and the limbs of one of the
greatest action stars of all time
drunken master snake in the Eagles
shadow was one of Chan's first lead
roles back in 1978 introducing his
distinct comic touch and distinguishing
him from the great Bruce Lee the movie
also featured rising star Huang Shang
Lee the king of the leg fighters whose
powerful kicks have become legend jangly
and Chan's on-screen chemistry was so
good that Jang Lee was cast as a villain
in Chan's follow up drunken master while
shooting snake jang lee had accidentally
kicked out one of Chan's teeth but Chan
had apparently failed to learn his
lesson he suffered one of his first
major onset injuries from one of Lee's
thundering kicks connected with his brow
bone breaking it and nearly causing him
to lose an eye in a 2014 interview
hawaiian jang lee was asked to rank his
top 5 kung-fu fighters and he didn't
hesitate to rank Jackie Chan at number
one project a in 1983's project de Hong
Kong police team up of the Coast Guard
to fight pirates at the turn of the 20th
century and it's pure slapstick comedy
by way of blinding martial arts and
insane stunts were one of the most
dangerous things Chan ever did appears
in the finished movie and it may have
been the first scene to give audiences
the notion that Chan may be superhuman
in the scene Chan's character Marv
dangles from the face of a 60-foot plug
tower but things don't go well
after losing his grip and falling six
stories through a couple of warnings
Chan lands directly on his head Chan
injured his spine during the stunt but
the camera doesn't cut away instead
extras dragged him to his feet and he
continues the scene police story the
police storied series has been
particularly hazardous to Chan starting
with the 1985 original at the climax of
a prolonged brawl inside a shopping mall
Chan jumps from a railing on to a pole
are covered in Christmas lights the
glass was fake to say Chan at least
wasn't sliced to ribbons but the lights
had heated up the pole causing him to
sustained serious burns on his hands the
hard landing also dislocated Chan's
pelvis and injured two vertebrae at
least the stunt looked great in the
finished film because there was no way
they were getting a second take armor of
God it was a completely routine shot
that resulted in Chan's closest brush
with mortality while shooting the 1986
film armor of God in Yugoslavia Chan had
to jump from the wall of a castle to a
nearby tree branch a maneuver that had
normally be able to pull off in his
sleep instead he came crashing down onto
the rocks below cracking his skull and
sending a piece of it into his brain
resulting in doctors having to put a
metal plate in his head it seems like
the kind of thing that might put an
action star out of commission for good
but the near fatal injury simply became
the highlight of armor of gods outtake
reel and over the next two decades Chan
would continue to risk it all for the
enjoyment of his millions of fans armor
of God to Operation Condor the second
film in the armor of God series released
in 1991 sees Chan in Indiana Jones mode
chasing after hidden treasure and
dealing with secret Colts and hidden
Nazi bases it's packed to the brim with
crazy fight sequences and stunts but it
was another reasonably simple task that
nearly took channels
clever editing hides chance a terrible
tumble drawing filming in the extended
scene Shanna actually loses his grip on
the chain and plummets to the ground
even though he had dislocated a sternum
he gives a thumbs up it could have been
worse if he had landed differently
he might have finished the job he
started on project day and dislocated
his head police story three super cop
it's safe to say that most leading men
have never had their face rearranged by
a helicopter but Jackie Chan is not most
leading men an incredibly perilous
sequence in 1992 s police story three
super cop has Chan leap onto a rope
ladder dangling from a chopper more the
pilots attempts to shake him off that
wasn't even the dangerous part when the
helicopter later lands on a moving train
all Chan has to do is avoid it as he
dangles from a rotating railway
apparatus
a Miss revealed in the outtakes resulted
in a fractured rib broken shoulder and a
dislocated cheekbone Shan had to hang on
with his good shoulder while
half-conscious waiting for the crew to
cut him down it's easy to see how much
worse it could have been
The Legend of drunken master it took 16
years for drunken master to receive a
sequel 1994's The Legend of drunken
master its climactic fight sequence is
legendary but it was almost very
different shun disagreed with the
director's vision for the final scene
and the conflict led to him quitting the
uncompleted production chan himself took
over directing duties and decided to
repeatedly risk lighting himself on fire
what makes a sequence even more amazing
is that the take in the finished film is
the second one Shan felt that the first
take it didn't have the proper rhythm so
he shot it again because he's apparently
invincible Who am I
1998 Who am I places Chan in the middle
of international intrigue working with a
CIA agent to solve a mystery surrounding
missing scientists while dodging hits
men in scenic locales and of course
performing one of the most insane stunts
ever puts a film Rotterdam in the
Netherlands is home to film Smurf one of
the world's more unique skyscrapers it
features a sloping glass facade that
runs down one entire side of the 24
story building in the climactic scene of
the film Qian slides down the entire
length of the facade
[Music]
chan accomplished the stunt by literally
just sliding down the entire length of
the facade unassisted with no harnesses
or other special equipment exactly as
seen in the film the slide takes nearly
45 seconds to complete before Chan comes
to a bone-jarring halt catching himself
from flying over the edge it took him
two weeks to work up the courage to
attempt what might be the most dangerous
stunt ever puts a film new Police Story
since the old police story series
obviously wanted him dead
chan could have been forgiven if it
wanted to skip the 2004 reboot new
police story burning characteristic
fashion he threw himself into the film's
kinetic action scenes with gusto in one
particularly terrifying scene Chan
pursues a gang member who distracts him
from the chase by gunning down the
driver of a loaded double-decker bus
Chan leaps onto the roof of the
out-of-control bus which proceeds to
cause massive property damage while the
hazards come at him fast and furious
[Music]
it's easy to spot about 200 things that
could have gone wrong during the filming
of the sequence any one of which could
have resulted in Chan literally losing
his head but if it weren't crazy
dangerous to shoot it wouldn't really be
a Jackie Chan movie thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]